ce à propos des 35 heures justement et
le débat est sur la table manuel valls
s'est également exprimé sur le sujet est
ce que vous vous estimez qu'il ne faut
pas payer plus cher les heures
travaillées au delà de 35 heures par
exemple vous mais moi je suis pour très
clairement la fin des 35 heures et là on
insiste est ce que vous êtes pour la fin
mai des heures supplémentaires je suis
pour que dans chaque entreprise
on puisse définir dans un cadre alors ça
peuvent être 39 heures la nouvelle par
exemple la nouvelle durée légale du
temps de travail c'est à partir à ce
moment là d'accord 40e heures je suis
favorable bien sûr pour contre 35 et 39
les gens puissent payer des heures qu'il
ferait mais je le pense je pense qu'en
tout cas ce que je souhaite moi c'est
que on est d accord de branche ou même
des référendum dans l'entreprise c'est
je pense la façon moderne demain de
pouvoir est connu un de pouvoir réaliser
l'économie c'est le parti des
propositions économiques que vous avez
mis sur la table récemment élevé qui
trouve écho d'ailleurs excusé
aujourd'hui le blocage donc aller dans
certains grands magasins parisiens qui
n'arrive pas à travailler le dimanche
par contre ce qu'il n'y a pas de
référence garder sur les 35 heures
regardez la cacophonie regarder chacun
joue sa partition entre le premier
ministre entre emmanuel macron on ne s'y
retrouve plus on n'a pas un orchestre on
n'a pas un chef d'orchestre
on a des solistes donc quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure que cette méthode
de françois hollande qui consiste à
jouer des uns sur les autres qui
consiste à ne pas trancher était
porteuse finalement d'anxiété je crois
que vous avez souligné qu'avec les 35
heures on a un vrai problème
aucune préoccupation d'intérêt général
ne légitiment plus la construction d'un
projet d'aéroport qui date de 1963
chacun le sait aujourd'hui ce projet
symbolise pour nos compatriotes
l'entêtement aveugle et 20 à promouvoir
des grands projets inutiles
elle dénonce un entêtement donc vain le
vôtre et d'autres dans la région depuis
des années a vu son pouvoir à un projet
inutile bien sûr alors projets inutiles
projet soutenu par trois prisons drague
public
successivement de droite et gauche
projets soutenus par six premiers
ministres projets soutenus par plusieurs
maires de nant par plusieurs présidents
de mêlée sans en changer
oui ou non les ont changé je vais vous
dire justement l'an dernier notre dame
enfin l'aéroport actuel a été celui et
c'est déjà le cas depuis dix ans en
europe par rapport aux autres
plateformes aéroportuaires c'est
l'aéroport nantes atlantique où le
trafic augmente le plus on a eu cent
trente huit journées de saturation donc
on voit bien que les écolos ne voudrait
sans doute plus d'aéroports en france ou
que on n'emprunte plus qu'on ne
développe plus ce moyen de transport ça
c'est un débat c'est un débat
démocratique
mais j'observe que ce projet a une
légitimité économique
c'est fondamental pour l'emploi pour la
croissance dans le grand ouest pour la
bretagne jean yves le drian le soutien
comme moi pour les pays de la loire
il a une légitimité démocratique droite
et gauche ont le soutien
voilà on parle souvent consensus là vous
avez un consensus droite gauche et enfin
il ya des décisions de justice
on a désormais 154 vous m'entendez bien
154 décision de justice favorable au
transfert vers port de nantes at il ya
plus de rue anonyme je souhaiterais que
madame duflot
non tout est rigoureusement les textes
sont rigoureusement évidemment respecter
et la commission européenne a eu à
connaître et à donner son accord
simplement je voudrais que madame duflot
puisse avoir une oreille attentive aux
souffrances des riverains voilà
simplement je le lui demande
très très sereinement on n'oublie pas
celle des gens qui sont attachés à leur
terre non plus
partir par mois depuis cinq générations
se dit encore plus de écoutez il ya plus
de 200 personnes qui fêtait des
habitants historiques qui ont si j'ose
dire donner leur accord à l'amiable
il ya quatre agriculteurs sur une
quarantaine qui ont été récalcitrants je
comprends que ça leur fasse mal et je ne
mésestime pas leur souffrance
simplement dans une démocratie un état
de droit il ya des décisions de justice
c'est le moyen de sortir de la violence
c'est le moyen de trancher des
différents parce que ce que ne dit pas
madame duflot et beaucoup d'écologie
c'est que il s'appuie sur la zad
évidemment pour combattre les reports et
ça c'est inacceptable parce que la zad
comme l'a dit le premier ministre je le
rejoins totalement sur les noms des
ultra-violents et j'ajoute ce sont des
ultra gauchiste alors et quand même il
ya des propos quand même qu'ils qui
semble alarmiste pour l'avenir exemple
sur publicsenat.fr josé bové dit qu'il
peut y avoir des troubles beaucoup plus
grave encore à l'ordre public le
chantage à la violence je sais le
chantait planches du chantage à la
violence et un chantage à la violence
les riverains qui ont fait il ya
quelques semaines qui ont brisé cette
loi du silence parce qu'il ya une loi du
silence et que à chaque fois que un
certain nombre de citoyens qui
respectueux de la loi et le droit
veulent sortir juste 27 pas du silence
ils subissent des représailles
elle nous entendent défendre ce projet
je vous entend dénoncer les opposants
j'ai l'impression de réentendre manuel
valls répondant à cécile duflot a écouté
j'ai j'ai vu deux fois manuel valls sur
ce projet quelques jours après
d'ailleurs que j'ai été élu président du
conseil régional
il m'avait tenus en privé les mêmes
propos et on vous le dit chapeau basque
ouais je lui dis chapeau je pense
qu'alors je vous dire j'ai aucun doute
sur la volonté de manuel valls
aucun doute j'ai une petite incertitude
désormais sur la décision un peu plus
hauts du président ali pour ramener la
décision du chef de l'état il ya une
cacophonie là encore au sommet de
l'exécutif oui il ya ségolène royal qui
fait se leurrer différentes déclarations
voilà façon très autonome il ya le
premier ministre bien sûr qu'ils aient
droit dans ses bottes et qui devra
trancher
c'est françois hollande j'espère qu'il
tranchera et qu' il respectera l'état de
droit la démocratie est un projet
capital pour la croissance j'ai entendu
à au moment de ses voeux françois
hollande je l' ai entendu proclamé cet
état d'urgence économique bien je dis
monsieur le président si vous êtes
attaché au développement à la croissance
donnée à l'ouest les moyens de son
attractivité territoriale dont
c'est l'histoire de l'arroseur arrosé la
des chances pour les binationaux
je pense que françois hollande lorsqu'il
s'est prononcée voulait en quelque sorte
piégée la droite en réalité il a piégé
son propre camp je vous renvoie quand
même ça n'est pas rien à la haute
autorité des tic présidée par maître
mignard que quelqu'un en plus que
j'estime pour indiquer pour lui que
cette est un débat qu'il fallait que la
gauche sans doute adoptent d'autres
choses nous il ya quelques voix
simplement il ya eu on nous reproche
souvent les républicains d'être un peu
gaulois de nous diviser de temps en
temps écoutez il ya eu autant nicolas
sarkozy l'autre jour une réunion et il
ya eu une quasi une très forte majorité
une case une amie témoins quelques voix
pour que on accepte tout cette déchéance
de nationalité pour les binationaux
encore une fois et contrairement à ce
que dit patrick devedjian tout
simplement parce que les binationaux
bénéficie d'un privilège d'une double
allégeance
voilà c'est tout à deux pays et donc
qu'ils soient privés d'une allégeance et
d'une nationalité lorsqu'ils ont commis
avec deux graves
ces nomades par contre les autres
doivent être punis tout autant tout
autant y compris d'ailleurs ils peuvent
aussi être déchus de leurs droits
civiques ça ne me gênerait pas du tout
bas gameiro on vous sent bien qu'à
l'elysée au parti socialiste qui a la
volonté de trouver un compromis une
solution médiane tout simplement vous
créé comme un mariage entre une autre
proposition vous restez vraiment lors
vous entendrez serré très fixé sur la
déchéance de nationalité sur les
ordinateurs alors considère que le
président république a pris un
engagement
ça n'est pas rien une réunion en congrès
il a pris devant les parlementaires est
en quelque sorte devant la
représentation nationale
par conséquent mois on a toujours dit
c'est oui si c'est ce cadre là si c'est
un autre cadre le sénat qui bénéficie
d'un droit de veto en matière
constitutionnelle
on est sur ce qu'on appelle un
bicamérisme parfait il n'ya pas le
dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale eh
bien on prendra le pouvoir qui nous est
donnée par la constitution pour amender
on a membres à ce que nous proposerait
si par exemple assemblée nous transmis
un texte qui n'est pas conforme à
l'engagement du président de la
république nous la vendrons voilà au
gouvernement mais il y aura pas de vote
spéciaux nalisation alors le problème en
raison de la république pas le vôtre
mais ses conséquences ici
présent république est pas capable de
mettre un peu d'ordre dans sa propre
majorité
il ya quand même une question qui se
pose mais michel le rappelait il ya des
divisions à gauche où la binationalité
pose problème vous m'ont dit si la
binationalité n'est pas inscrite on ne
votera pas est-ce que du coup cette
réforme est vouée à l'échec
elle peut l'être et peut l'être alors il
faut aussi parce qu'on l'a demandé il
faut regarder les textes qui vont
accompagner le texte constitutionnel
puisque le texte constitutionnel va
modifier un article de la constitution
peu importe est renvoyé à notamment une
loi organique donc on a demandé à ce que
tous soient sur la table pour que on l
économie générale du texte et qu'on
compare les dispositions qui nous seront
données par la voie constitutionnelle ou
par la voie d'une autre loi pour que
l'on sache où on va et ce que nous
allons voter alors les choses sont
claires
voilà les choses sont claires si c'est
l'engagement des prisons de république
au congrès si oui si ça ne l'est pas ce
sera non en tout cas pour le sénat on
attendra on dirait pas non brutalement
alors on reviendra peut-être tout à
l'heure vous avez dit chapeau à manuel
valls à vous vous adressez à françois
hollande
vous lui dites vous l'avez traité
d'indécis vous dites que c'est un
tacticien qui va le prendre et des
paiements sont dans le tapis je n'ai pas
traité d'indécis simplement il avait
accusé la décision il est très habile
écoutez il est allé très habile et là je
trouve que le talent qu'il met souvent
dans l'habileté politique je pense qu'il
ferait mieux de le mettre
mais maintenant dans la réforme sont là
en risque de se retourner contre lui si
je vous soumets j'ai pu écouter stands
et j'attends demain
ouais j'attends demain pour l'instant ce
ceux comme le on me dit c'est que il
proclame son attachement à son
engagement alors pour l'instant je fais
confiance nous dit depuis le début
j'attends demain bruno retailleau est ce
que vous trouvez normal en tant que
parlementaire qu'à la veille de la
présentation de ce texte devant la
commission et après une journée ces
stations vous ne sachiez toujours pas
c'est un autre problème
oui là non c'est pas très normal vous
avez complètement raison je préfère
d'ailleurs ce soit vous qu'ils disaient
plutôt que moi parce que on va me
trouver
est ce que ça veut dire que la journée
de consultation de vendredi n'a servi à
rien
françois hollande qui a rencontré tous
les parlementaires un vendredi pour
parler de ce texte
tu pas si ça sert à grand chose il faut
il faut sans doute consulter là encore
réponse demain je vous dirai demain tant
qu' on n'a pas de réponse crible on n'a
pas de réponse je voudrais évoquer avec
vous une polémique qui continuent de
prendre l'ampleur de l'ampleur depuis ce
week-end c'est canal+ ce soit si vous
avez vu les images vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler qu'à convié
donc sur son plateau en présence que
najat vallaud belkacem un responsable
d'une ong musulmanes 1 qui a refusé
devant les caméras de condamner le
groupe etat islamique et qui a pressé
qu'il ne serrerait pas la main des
femmes est à nouveau la ministre d'une
question nationale a été interpellé
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale sur
ce sujet et la justifier et bien son
attitude en l'écoutent
je condamne évidemment les propos qui
ont été tenus par ce président
d'association sur ce plateau
je regrette qu'on lire offert une
tribune une fois encore l'école est
totalement engagée pour transmettre les
valeurs que nous sommes en train de
défendre car nous n'avons qu'un ennemi
de part et d'autre de cette assemblée
je vous invite à ne pas abîmer ce
travail par des polémiques dérisoires on
vient d'entendre un athlète vallaud
belkacem est ce que cette justification
n'arrive pas un peu tard est-ce qu'elle
n'aurait pas dû être plus ferme d'une
faute évidemment c'est une faute
elle dit elle même elle le reconnaît en
quelque sorte puisqu'il dit on n'aurait
jamais dû donner une tribune mais par sa
seule présence
elle a solennisé cette tribu et l'aurait
dit parti c'est un salafiste ilna il a
refusé de condamner l'état islamique
on a encore vu sur internet en tout cas
on en a entendu parler je ne les ai pas
vus mais vos collègues vous même vous en
avez fait fait état de ces tueries de
cette barbarie
je pense que canal n'avait pas l'inviter
même s'il ya une course à l'audience
mais la course à l'audience ne justifie
pas tout et malheureusement najat
vallaud belkacem a manqué comment
dirais-je de discernement elle aurait dû
quitter le plateau parce qu' elle ne
représente pas que l'école est elle est
ministre elle représente le gouvernement
elle représentait la france et c'est une
grave défaillance
vous avez peut-être lu le livre de
nicolas sarkozy ce jeu les reçus et je
vais commencer à le lire tout à l'heure
voilà peut-être vu en tout cas ses
déclarations sur leur mariage pour tous
après avoir dit pendant la campagne pour
la présidence de l'ump qu'il était qu'on
pouvait réécrire voir abroger cette fois
ci il dit que le remède serait pire que
le mal
donc ils changent de position sur le
sujet quelle est votre opinion par
rapport à ça bah écoutez mon opinion
mais elle n'a pas changé moi j'ai
combattu cette loi et les événements
m'ont renforcer dans la conviction je
pense qu' il ne faut surtout pas
marginalisés ou vouloir exclure de notre
communauté homosexuelle je pense que
consacrer un amour entre deux êtres
je n'y vois aucun inconvénient on peut
transformer justement ce texte avec une
réécriture donc une abrogation sur la
partie unions civiles mais la filiation
poser problème notamment avec la gpa
vous savez parfaitement que en france hp
a en réalité elle est interdite par le
code civil mais qu' on a une hypocrisie
totale puisque des sociétés américaines
viennent très régulièrement avec des
livres et qui montre des centaines de
femmes qui sont réduites au haut rang
finalement de bestiaux il faut les
choisir blonde petit etc et on loue des
ventres voilà parce que il faut donner
ce droit à l'enfant c'est ça que je
comptais assoyez je pense que la gpa la
gestation pour autrui c'est une
déshumanisation c'est une
marchandisation réel donc moi je dis oui
mais par joni wiman union civile pour
consacrer un amour entre deux êtres deux
femmes deux hommes qui peuvent s'ébattre
mariage mais mais en revanche ou non
parce que le prêt du mariage c'est que
ça importe en droit français c'est
compliqué a à dire et expliquer mais ça
emporte cette filiation et si vous
donnez cette filiation
il ya un moment donné vous buter sur
cette idée de la gestation pour autrui
tu l'aurais mois la gestation pour
autrui
je pense que ça encourage toutes les
dérives
ses encours à souder ray je pense que le
droit à l'enfant ne doit pas conduire
si vous voulez à ce genre de dérive là
on entend votre position qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire du
candidat sarkozy écoutez moi je suis
président de groupe
je m'interdis les pitres donc c'est un
sujet l'interdît les petites phrases sur
ma famille politique à son bord des cils
et vous avez porté c'est un sujet que
j'ai portée et et moi je pense que il
faut être droit dans ses convictions je
lés dit tout à l'heure et et je reste si
vous voulez opposés et je pense que
alors évidemment quand il a tort nicolas
sarkozy donc il a tort mais je ne suis
pas sur sa position il a tort de changer
d'avis je ne suis pas sur sa position
voilà et évidemment vous cherchez un tir
plein mal samedi dans le jeu le
colombien ya une question et je peux au
moins affirmer ce à quoi je crois
qu'elles sont mes convictions sans taper
sur mes amis solidaires qui est la
question de fond derrière c est ce que
ce sujet préoccupe encore l'électorat au
sens large et l'électorat de droite au
sens plus rester ni violée non mais je
pense qu'il ya une évolution
effectivement et quand je il ya dix ans
l'union civile c'était compliqué à
expliquer ces voix là et je sens que
cette évolution et les murs et je pense
que les gens peuvent l'accepter mais je
pense que depuis le début ce qui a
suscité beaucoup beaucoup de
mobilisations s'étaient pas cela c'était
pas que la république consacre ce lien
dont ont besoin les personnes non on
peut parfaitement et dans le plus grand
respect dans plus profond respect le
concevoir
c'est le problème de la filiation qui
conduit inévitablement à l'heure à des
dérives
pour madame taubira pourquoi est ce que
le ministère public aujourd'hui ne
poursuit pas les sociétés américaines
qui viennent faire du beurre sur la
faiblesse vélo qu'à l'étranger
pourquoi vous pourquoi alors que c'est
une contradiction avec l'état de droit
vous évoquez la filiation le droit à
l'enfant ce n'est pas forcément la
revendication des couples qui se marient
aujourd'hui il revendait ses livres ont
le droit à l'égalité du mariage
numérique douala au mariage bien sûr
mais vous savez ce concept d'égalité
voilà quand vous faites les choses au
nom de l'égalité et bien vous avez un
couple d'hommes qui dit moi écouter je
veux légalité et l'égalité pour moi
c'est le droit à l'enfant puisque deux
femmes peuvent recourir par des moyens
qui effectivement sont eux aussi
interdits
à la pma nous on veut aussi l'égalité et
on veut pouvoir avoir le droit à
l'enfant
donc on voit bien que ce concept
d'égalité doit à mon avis être dépassé
par un autre concept qui est l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant et qui est un
concept par exemple de della nonna
disponibilité du corps humain de non
marchandisation de sécurisation de la
deûle à position par rapport à la loi
taubira vous pensez que ça va être un
enjeu majeur de la de la primaire va
vous dit vous savez on est déjà là il ya
la primaire effectivement elle et elle
est à la fin de l'année je pense que
c'est sans doute un enjeu je pense que
et j'observe aujourd'hui que la
population française vit une double
crise une crise économique mais en même
temps une crise d'identité une crise
culturelle elle a besoin de repères le
mariage ça fait partie des repères et la
filiation alors là je peux vous dire que
c'est inscrit dans les gènes de notre
société donc ça peut aussi mobilisé un
certain nombre vous imaginez demain
condé marie jeu seulement
non non pas bon non mais il faut pas
caricaturer il faut pas qui a été non je
crois que on pourra pas des mariés ceux
qui sont mariés voilà ce qu'ils ont
évidemment ça ne peut s'appliquer si le
texte est réformé ça ne peut s'appliquer
que pour l'avenir
on n'est pas des fous furieux il peut
pas y avoir de rétroactivité
dans ce domaine là et cet argument du
des mariages il est trop caricatural
veut dire je sais que ça peut
fonctionner autour d'un plateau mais non
faut être de ce point de vue là très
claire et elle sera en même temps voilà
c'est tout c'est simplement pour éviter
des dérives